I need you to fix his suit the suit is
literal perfection it will be when it
fits a woman we're so excited about that
woman this is a character that fans have
known and loved for so many years but
you guys are bringing your new stamped
to it what can you tell me about what
makes this bat woman stand out from
others well for one there isn't another
bat woman so that was kind of a it was a
good opportunity to kind of know that it
hasn't been played before so if you're
playing Batman you're playing Catwoman
you're playing an iconic role from a
comic that's already been made into
live-action you sort of have to there's
a fine line between playing homage to
someone else that's done it but also
differentiating and finding nuances that
make it unique to you so being able to
do this with a complete clean slate and
just really relying on the comics for
where I'm gonna grab character bits and
nuances and things she does and think
she says and then of this is the writing
because our version is gonna be mixtures
of comics and then also Caroline and and
Sara and all the producers and writers
turning this into like a fully fledged
show that will probably be hopefully
touchwood these things are wood but you
know whatever could go for a very long
time so it's it's fun when you get to
build a character from the ground up and
it's nerve-racking when people already
have an expectation of what that
character looks like to them so it's
sort of it's like a double-edged sword
but I'm having so much fun with it well
and you're already breaking boundaries
because Batwoman is the first openly
lesbian person to lead a super show
which is so fantastic how does that make
you feel as an actress it's I feel like
I get that wasn't that question a lot
and I know I get the gravity of it I
totally understand its enormous and it's
groundbreaking and it's all these things
and it's taking all these boxes that
haven't been you know takes before but I
kind of remove myself from that external
idea of it of what it is beyond the show
and and just kind of I mean the
character right now and I'm in the show
right now and I'm that's why I fly like
flew in from Vancouver night shoots to
here to then talk about it it's great
but I I think the thing that kind of
Caroline and I shared the same kind of
thread in is that we wish that there was
a show like this and we were young and
there wasn't and so for me it's like
when I go to work every morning
every night whenever we're doing our
schedules I'm reminded that this is a
choice that I wish existed when I was
young then that gives me the purpose to
to go to work and that gives me that
extra drive but once I'm at work it's
like that isn't like I'm even thinking
about I'm just thinking about Kate and
I'm thinking about that woman and I'm
thinking about you know all different
kinds of things and Gotham and it's it's
sort of you know it's it's it's larger
than than that for me but at the same
time I am so thrilled that we're at a
place in the world where this is even a
possibility there's five years ago ten
years ago you know wouldn't have been do
you feel like that adds any additional
pressure to you
not really yeah I mean like I'm you know
I'm gay gay yesterday the gay tomorrow
okay next week and I play a gay
character it kind of doesn't feel like
okay now I've got to be like super gay I
gotta be Batwoman gay Kate Kane gay like
they're not like they're not different
versions of gay and I kind of feel like
it's not a gay show like yes we have a
lesbian lead and that's the
groundbreaking that's fantastic but you
know there are straight people in the
show to you it's a diverse cast there's
a lot of great things about it and I
don't feel like we even play on that
aspect definitely not any more than like
a heterosexual show and you never say
like and this is a true sexual superhero
and this is the gauge to be heard it's
kind of the same and my relationships
there with women and I have a family
family dynamic I have you know trauma
and all these things just people have in
their life and one of the aspects of it
is she's gay she likes girls mm-hmm it's
kind of like for me it's not a big deal
well also love is love and the fact that
we get to see you have such great
chemistry on-screen has been so exciting
for all the future shippers out there
are you ready for that level of
attention that social media shipping I'm
not like that
in social media you know I like I
daren't I don't pay a lot of attention
to it I'm not on Twitter I've had
comments disabled from Instagram for
like way before that one was even you
know announced or that I knew that I
would be doing it because I find it kind
of distracting from you know I have
something that I want to parts in its
life but I went to price because it's
fun all rights my dogs or its new
haircut or whatever it is I'm promoting
something and the last thing I needed
here is like I love that haircut that I
got sucks you know I love that top why
those shoes like it
it's irrelevant to me and I feel like
then I started finding myself which I'm
sure many people do like trying to
curate to get more people to like
something and you know but if you don't
like that hat you like this hat and then
I'll say what am i doing this is like
taking up part of my real life yeah and
that's like not real life so for me it's
like I don't I don't feel the pressure
of that either cuz I literally don't
have to say it because it's I don't have
access to it but I am kind of excited to
see if you they're gonna root for
relationship-wise because I know that's
a very big aspect of what people get
involved in and these and I've watched
our and I was like Felicity all of us
Felicity don't like and I'm that person
so like I'm starting to see what people
are gonna who they're gonna gravitate
towards yeah but yeah talk about your
suit yeah so incredible take me back to
the first moment you tried it on I was
in I don't know we're in LA and in some
sort of industrial ish area was I know
the first one was like at Colleen's
anyway sorry about regular programming I
was at Colleen's and I was walking
through just she is magnificent you know
she's won Oscar Awards numerous times
and so you're walking through and you're
seeing like these big costumes and these
all the questions that she's ever done
and these you know statues and you're
like so I'm gonna have one of these like
this is gonna be designed
I was scanned I was measured by hand I
was photographed from every single angle
I was I mean things that I didn't even
know what like possible I was invited
and next to better than better data
there and I'm sure they have my inside
somewhere I don't know I one time I
walked in there's like 12 of my heads
and I was like this is very
uncomfortable I mean I could probably
climb me at this point who knows if I
took DNA but when I put the suit on it
was like a second skin you know and it's
it's always fun Halloween or kids
parties or whenever you dress up as your
favorite superhero but it's sort of
different when it's a real suit and it
really no one else can wear that suit it
fits only me and you put it on and then
you have the belt and then you have the
gauntlets and you have the gloves and
you have the
sort of different little gadgets that I
have in batarangs and the cowl and the
it's just and you put it on and for the
first time that you do it I don't think
you'll ever feel that ever again so you
just have to embrace it and you just
like this is incredible like I feel you
kind of think you're gonna feel funny
and then you actually put it on and
you're like oh I feel like I could go on
fight crime
like anyone anyone have a crime though
me to buy it because I am ready I'm
gonna be faster and stronger and better
and then you're like on a second it's
pinching my back can we without better
the same here
but yeah it was it was incredible and
and having Colleen design that I think
is just we're very lucky I'm so excited
about all the stunts on your show even
just in the pilot you guys have really
set such a high bar very scared you know
you get a month to shoot a pilot and
then you got like a week to shoot an
episode and that stunt that we did there
was like a basically a wanna I don't
know it wasn't one shot but it was old
like we just did it all the way through
I mean that's like 27 moves or something
so of course everyone's gonna be like
the stunt coordinator now it's the 28th
let's even get 30 let super me do 48 it
was like oh my god my brain they fun to
do great great stunt people they're
working with my strengths so that makes
it easier like my boxing background
things I've already done luckily and
then Alice played by Rachel she gets to
do all these cool tricks with like this
knife nose like I want to learn that and
and then I literally busted up my
knuckles like that's yours did you take
that that's Jo you do that so we have
what we're good at are our own things
well because Rachel was saying like
there's nothing that Ruby can't do did
we just find something yeah I totally
did I was like that butterfly knife that
looks really Oh
let me try again ow I was like this you
guys have this like a trick to this like
no you're just really bad aside from the
butterfly nice has there been any other
mishaps or anything that we need to
protect you from not not that I can
think of I think that you always get
like little I definitely had like a
little black eye at one point I
definitely had like a little caught in
my lip but that happens on everything
it's just like you're doing stunts
you're rolling around you're throwing
things you're doing all this crazy stuff
and then you kind of like I feel great
cuz your adrenalin so high and you watch
it like nailed it and then you're like I
don't ii Oh someone punch me and then
you lie you get home and you're covered
in bruises but it's a lot of the fun
we're gearing up for an epic five part
cross hopper meant we were introduced to
bat woman in our last crossover so you
got a little taste of it how are you
feeling going into this one and knowing
that this is really gonna be the last
time you're gonna work with Steven a
mouth that maybe not mouth but um when I
walked into the crossover I was like hi
guys
I'm new this is fantastic I had to play
bat woman and they were just like Hello
Steven was like where am I Who am I and
I was like oh I see it's it's like that
because it was like this seventh night
of night shoots no one had slept and now
like oh it's Ruby hold on and they kind
of must it up every little bit of energy
they had left to give me a hug and that
worked so excited but I could see like
in between conversation the savin was
kind of like and so I feel like that's
gonna be me this year like I'm not gonna
be the one walking and being like hey
this is great isn't this amazing we're
all gonna be there like trying to get
sleep in between every minute that we
get because it's five hours five
crossovers and then we're all shooting
our own series at the same time so it's
like it's a scheduling nightmare I feel
like Phil the worst for them really the
people
schedule this together but having
legends Supergirl I really want to work
with Melissa again and that's Supergirl
Batwoman dynamic Steven grant I mean
it's gonna be unbelievable it's gonna be
amazing
yeah well lastly what is one thing that
you want future fans of that woman to
know before they tune in to the show
what do I want future fans of that woman
to know before they tune in to the show
I don't know they just they're in for
like a hell of a ride like honestly you
think you know something you think you
know someone and you don't and just wait
for that twist at the end of the pilot
you think that's a twist wait till the
ones that I keep getting every week it's
it's wild it's really good
I'm not about to let a man take credit
for a woman's work